- [Voiceover] So what we're
gonna do in this video
is several examples where
we evaluate expressions
with definite integrals
and so right over here we
have the definite integral
from negative two to three of 2 f(x)dx
plus the definite integral
from 3 to seven of
3 f(x)dx
and all we know about f(x)
is the graph of y=f(x)
from negative, from x equals negative six
to x equals seven.
They also give us the areas between
f(x), y equals f(x)
and the x axis.
The negative areas show that our function
is below the x axis
and so given that,
can we evaluate that
and like always,
pause the video and see if
you can do it on your own.
Well the first thing that
my brain wants to do is
I want to,
I want to take these
constants out of the integral
because then once they're out
and I'm just taking the
straight up definite integrals
of f(x),
I can relate that to the areas over here
and I know I can do that
and this is a very common
integration property
and applies to definite
and indefinite integrals
but if I'm taking the integral of
k f(x)dx,
this is the same thing as k
times the integral of f(x)dx.
So let's just apply that property there
which is really you're
taking the scaler outside
of the integral.
To say this is going to be the same thing
as two times the definite
integral from negative two
to three of f(x)dx plus
three times the integral from
three to seven of f(x)dx.
All right.
Now can we evaluate these things?
So what is this going to be?
The definite integral
from negative two to three
of f(x)dx.
Well we can view that as the area
between the curves y
equals f(x) and the x axis,
between x equals negative
two and x equals three.
So between x equals two
and x equals three,
they give us the area
between y equals f(x)
and the x axis.
It is seven.
So this thing over here
is seven
and then we have the
integral from three to seven
of f(x)
so we're gonna go from three to seven
and once again,
well this is going to evaluate
to a negative value
because f(x) is below the x axis there
and it's going to evaluate
to negative three.
So this is all going to be
this is going to be two
times seven so 14 plus,
14 plus three times negative three
so plus negative nine
and so 14 minus nine is equal to five.
This is fun.
Let's do more of these.
All right.
Okay, so here this first integral
the integral from zero to five
of f(x)dx,
so this is pretty straightforward.
This right over here,
we're gonna go from zero to five.
Zero to five
and of f(x)dx,
so we're talking about this area there
which they tell us is four
so that was pretty easy to evaluate
and now we're gonna subtract,
we're gonna subtract
going from negative eight
to negative four times 2f(x),
well let's just take this two outside.
So if we just take this two outside,
then this just becomes the
integral from negative eight
to negative four of f(x)
and so this thing,
this thing right over here
evaluates to five.
It's this area they're talking about.
So this is all going to simplify to
four minus that two that we brought out,
minus two times five.
Times five, which is equal to
let's see four minus 10
which is equal to negative six.
All right.
Let's do another one of these.
So here I have the integral
from negative seven
to negative five
so I'm going from negative seven
which is, it's gonna be right around there
so I want to find,
I want to find this area
right over here.
So I want to find that area.
That's that
and then I'm gonna go from
negative five to zero.
So then this is going to be
going from negative five to zero
so it's gonna be all of that.
Now there's a couple of
ways you can think about
doing it.
You can assume I have some symmetry here
and they don't tell it for sure
but it looks very symmetric
around x equals negative five
so you could assume that this eight
is split between these two regions
but an easier way to do it
is just to realize look,
I went from negative seven
to negative five
and then from negative five to zero
and I'm integrating the same thing.
F(x)dx
so this integral I can rewrite
as the integral from negative seven
so negative seven all the way to zero
of f(x), f(x)dx
and so really that's just going to be
the net area between negative seven
and zero
and so we have the positive eight there
so this is going to be
equal to the positive eight
and then we have the negative one there
so minus one
which is equal to seven.